[Música]
[Aplausos]
muy bien tomé esta medicación cada ocho
horas durante dos semanas y si no se
siente mejor llamé a mi secretaria que
sólo atiende por la mañana y pide un
turno si nos volvemos a ver espero que
esté mejor hasta luego
peretti
no one
cuando han tales
no vino y no ha visto
ahora sí peretti
juan peretti
como llevada adelante tome asiento y
dígame qué es lo que le sucede
juan gonzález llegó a tiempo a la
consulta médica esperó por más de dos
horas y no fue atendido cuando fue a
consultar que lo que estaba sucediendo
nadie lo entendió saben por qué porque
juan es sordo cuando escuchó que lo
estaban llamando como esta situación las
cuales suceden otras cuando va a ser un
trámite personal cuando voy al
supermercado puesto cuando va un quiosco
siempre necesita de un familiar o de un
amigo que les sirva de nexo comunicativo
-juan ingreso a la universidad necesita
de un intérprete de lengua de señas que
lo acompañe pero la universidad no
cuenta con dicho servicio la misma
empezó los trámites necesarios pero como
es la necesidad de la minoría bueno los
trámites llevan su tiempo juan llegó a
julio y terminó abandonando hoy se
encuentra desocupado envió su currículum
a diferentes empresas de la ciudad pero
cuando llegó a la entrevista personal no
fue entendido por qué juan utiliza la
lengua natural
personas sordas es la lengua de señas es
la lengua no un lenguaje de señas no de
signos y esa argentina no argentinas
como dijo fabi recién la lengua de señas
es la lengua natural de las personas
sordas tiene una gramática propia que es
diferente que la que nosotros utilizamos
para escribir para comunicarnos por eso
la lengua de señas debe estar enseñada
por una persona sorda porque la persona
sorda cuando como enseña su lengua y la
transmite también nos enseña sobre su
cultura sobre su forma de vida sobre las
cosas que le pasan sobre cómo se
comunica con los demás por eso es
importante respetarla y entender que es
diferente de nuestra lengua
ustedes qué piensan sobre la lengua de
señas alguna vez la habrán escuchado
creen que es universal o que para cada
país tiene su propia lengua de señas que
creen
muy bien cada país tiene su propia
lengua de señas por eso si yo viajo a
eeuu se va a utilizar la lengua de señas
americana si viajo a españa la lengua de
señas española y así estado país al que
voy se va a utilizar una lengua de señas
distintas como nosotras las personas
oyentes tenemos los distintos idiomas
bueno así ocurre con la lengua de señas
de acuerdo al país una lengua de señas
diferentes piensen un poco alguna vez
escucharon algunos términos como por
ejemplo en mi barrio hay un chico que es
sordo mudo o el otro día leí en el
diario sordo mudo ganó una medalla en
tal cosa el hipo acústico le pasó tal
otra esos términos están mal utilizados
saben por qué porque una persona sorda
premuda ustedes se pusieron a pensar en
el significado de las palabras
sordo tiene que ver con la sordera y
mudo tiene que ver con las cuerdas
vocales las personas sordas pueden hacer
sonidos algunas pueden hablar y con
respecto al termino hipoacústicos la
acústica tiene que ver con un lugar y no
con una persona así que esos dos
términos están mal utilizados quizás no
sabemos cómo nombrarlos pero hoy podemos
que las personas que son sordas son
aquellas que tienen una pérdida total de
la audición es decir que no escuchan los
sonidos del ambiente en cambio las
personas hipoacúsicas son aquellas que
escuchan diferentes sonidos tienen una
pérdida parcial en uno o en ambos oídos
esta pérdida puede variar de leve a
moderada por eso es la diferenciación de
sonidos que pueden escuchar por eso los
términos correctos para nombrar son
personas sordas o personas hipoacúsicas
lo cual no son sinónimos
muy bien algunas personas también
piensan que todos los sordos pueden leer
los labios ustedes que piensan
muy bien ahí hay más dudas que la
pregunta anterior las personas sordas no
todas pueden leer los labios y de hecho
es un proceso que lleva una gran
cantidad de entrenamiento así que no
estén esperando que las personas sordas
les lean los labios porque es algo muy
difícil imagínense si hoy se apaga el
micrófono y solamente los que están
adelante se escucharían un poquito más
tal vez con mirarme los labios no se
enterarían de lo que estoy diciendo pero
los que están en el fondo mucho menos
prueben su casta a bajar el volumen del
televisor cuando están mirando algún
locutor o algún noticiero y traten de
adivinar lo que está diciendo para ver
qué es muy difícil a las personas sordas
les pasa lo mismo muchas veces en la
tele las imágenes que acompañan a veces
se divide en dos la pantalla y está el
locutor de un lado una imagen del otro y
abajo van pasando subtítulos muchas
veces estas tres cosas no están
relacionadas porque abajo pasan
subtítulos de otra noticia a la persona
sorda le pasa lo mismo que no entiende
nada o a veces con la lectura la vía
puede entender distintas palabras
entonces no comprende el mensaje en su
totalidad cuando nos encontramos con una
persona sorda tampoco elige especulemos
tanto hola cómo estás sobre samu porque
esto
no hace que esté aclaró el mensaje y la
persona sorda va a pensar que le estamos
tomando el pelo nos estamos burlando de
ella también como sociedad creemos que
las personas sordas se utilizan la
lengua de señas en la primera infancia a
futuro no van a hablar la adquisición de
la lengua de señas en la primera
infancia lo que aporta es comunicación
el conocimiento del mundo es poder
elegir entre un objeto y otro poder
llamar a sus padres como también poder
expresar sus sentimientos teniendo esta
lengua de base la adquisición de la
lengua oral y de la lengua escrita va a
ser mucho más fácil nosotros con danny
nos cruzamos con gente en la calle y nos
dice para qué voy a aprender lengua de
señas si yo me bajo desde internet el
alfabeto dactilológico y con eso sale
deletreo todo y me sirve el alfabeto
dactilológico es lo que es para nosotros
el abecedario pero solamente con
movimientos de la mano pensemos si nos
dicen un mensaje
lee en un cuento o hasta nos hacen una
instrucción sobre toda letra a letra
entenderíamos no solamente con suerte
nos quedaríamos con la última letra que
nos han realizado entonces ya sepamos
que para usar este letrero dactilológico
lo usamos cuando nos cruzamos por
primera vez si no nos conocemos cada uno
dice su nombre luego tenemos una seña
personal también para indicar un
domicilio o cuando estamos trabajando y
hay unas una palabra que enseña no tiene
entonces la deletrea mos y explicamos su
significado
también nos pasa que dice para que voy a
aprender lengua de señas y yo en mi
familia no tengo ningún sordo ningún
hipoacúsico la lengua de señas no se
utiliza solamente con estas personas la
lengua de señas se puede utilizar con
niños con otras patologías como por
ejemplo trastorno del espectro autista
síndrome de down parálisis cerebral o no
verbal es donde la pronunciación o la
articulación de la palabra presenta
dificultad lo que aporta la lengua de
señas no con su gramática propia sino
que tomando de ellas voz palabras
vocabulario lo que aporta es
comunicación una vez que los niños
pueden observar que son entendidos que
su entorno lo comprende la fonación la
articulación de la palabra empieza a ser
más fácil por eso en este caso la lengua
de señas se toma como comunicación
aumentativa y alternativa
muy bien tienen ganas de jugar lo veo
muy tranquilo muy silencioso todos muy
atentos con fabi le proveemos un juego
no es así yo les vamos a ir diciendo
algunas palabras y ustedes pónganse a
pensar y hagan una seña un gesto lo
primero que no sé hablar que se les
venga a la mente sobre estas palabras
que le vamos a decir si están listos
vamos a más no se tienen que parar nada
muy bien como saludarían a alguien y le
dirían hola
perfecto en lengua de señas de esta
manera se dice o la lengua de señas
argentina o la y el número uno
y el número 23 y hasta el 5 es lo mismo
y como dirían que alguien es preciso
como para vivir
y alto como danny
excelente lengua de señas de la misma
manera si alguien es muy alto se puede
levantar un poco y ahí expresa que es
mucho más alto y como dirían que alguien
es tacaño
pasado
al asad en esta calle muy bien y no sé
excelente
y para decir que sí
y para decir que no
otra forma de decir que no
gracias y cuando estén muy enojados
también dicen no pórtate bien no creo no
le creo nada a usted pero yo no digo así
yo digo no
y ahí se termina todo
pero que agregué rasgos no manuales mi
rostro y en mi cuerpo en la lengua de
señas
que se denominan rasgos no manuales los
cuales indican y aseveran la palabra se
clarifican dieron con danny que hicimos
hacer este juego porque queríamos
demostrarles que ustedes tienen un
montón de estrategias y herramientas
para cuando se encuentran con una
persona sorda poder comunicarse sabemos
que al momento de saber que sordo a
todos nos agarra un colapso nervioso
pero ojo hoy pudimos demostrar solamente
algunas sabemos que hay un montón de
señas que son como naturales comunes lo
importante es que cuando nos damos
cuenta que la persona que está en frente
nuestro es sorda que los miremos nos
calmemos y de a poco las estrategias van
a ir apareciendo sin ninguna de estas
herramientas que les brindamos hoy nos
sirve podemos dramatizar podemos la chs
hacer la acción que nosotros pretendemos
que el otro realice
si esto tampoco clarifica podemos hacer
un dibujo o escribir un ace o una
oración sencilla como también con el uso
de las nuevas tecnologías podemos buscar
desde internet una imagen y le mostramos
a la persona sorda dicha imagen y ellos
nos van a brindar la seña
correspondiente lo importante es tener
la intención comunicativa y así va a ser
todo mucho más fácil se acuerdan lo que
le pasó a juan gonzález al principio que
tenía que pasar del médico el médico no
sabía que juan era sordo y juan nunca
entraba al consultorio bueno esta
situación se hubiera podido solucionar
muy fácilmente de varias maneras podría
hacer que en el consultorio médico
existiera un visor con el número
entonces juan cuando ve el número de
orden de turno se da cuenta y pasa
también podría hacer que con una
aplicación de ven celular se le avisará
a juan que tiene que ingresar
posibilidad que no cuestan nada de
dinero y que es muy sencilla si el
médico hubiera sabido que juan era sordo
podría haber escrito en un papel su
nombre y apellido no quedarse sentado
detrás de su escritorio salir mostrar el
papel hacia afuera y juán cuando lee su
nombre podría haberse enterado de que le
tocaba pasar en nuestra ciudad hay un
montón de personas sordas muchas más
personas de las que hoy están en este
lugar imagínense mucha gente que a lo
mejor puede ser nuestro vecino alguien
del barrio es sorda las personas sordas
si bien se hicieron muchos avances en
nuestra ciudad y algunas cosas por
ejemplo tienen e intérpretes cuando hay
algún acto no existe un servicio de
intérprete al que puedan ir a pedir
ayuda cuando sucede algo o pedir por un
intérprete por ejemplo para que los
acompañe a hacer una denuncia policial
si hay un accidente de tránsito tampoco
tienen a quien pedir
para que los acompañe o los la misma
policía a veces no sabe a dónde pedir
por un intérprete porque les aparece
alguna persona sorda en la comisaría
imagínense una persona sorda que vive
sola tiene un accidente en su casa o se
incendia a su casa pase para llamar a
los bomberos como llama a la policía
como llama la gur no puede como les dije
antes es difícil esta situación en
nuestra ciudad una persona sorda que
tiene que ir al médico por ejemplo al
proctólogo oa la ginecóloga no tiene a
donde pedir un intérprete entonces qué
hacen cuando tienen alguna actividad así
o alguna reunión de padres por ejemplo
adultos sordos que tienen reunión de sus
hijos oyentes le piden a un conocido
algún vecino algún amigo que más o menos
los entiende que los acompañen
esto a veces es difícil porque tienen
que compartir información por ejemplo en
el médico una ginecóloga tienen que
compartir información sensible con otra
persona y si la persona es familiar o
conocido a veces toma decisiones por la
persona sorda porque lo conoce y esto no
está bien porque las personas sordas
tiene el mismo derecho que nosotros a
elegir a decidir a opinar es muy
importante que les demos su lugar y que
respetemos sus decisiones a nadie le
gustaría tener que ir al médico oa una
ginecóloga a las mujeres con nuestra
mamá o con nuestra hija pensemos un
poquito en estas situaciones porque se
dan todos los días también cuando vemos
a un grupo de personas sordas
comunicarse a todos nos llama muchísimo
la atención y quedamos por tiempos
prolongados mirando sus manos
recordemos que en sus manos está su voz
ellos se sienten intimidados con lo
mismo que nos pasa a nosotros cuando nos
damos cuenta que la persona que está
tras nuestro está escuchando nuestra
conversación
también creemos que la única forma de
poder incluirlos es invitarlos a actos o
eventos y cantar las canciones en lengua
de señas una canción en lengua de señas
implica un trabajo previo donde se tiene
que trabajar el sentimiento y el mensaje
que el autor quiso dar a dicha letra
pero nunca le preguntamos a las personas
sordas si en verdad le gusta que le
cante más canciones en lengua de señas
porque siempre los ponemos como
espectadores porque no los ponemos como
protagonista de esta historia porque no
les preguntamos qué actividades le
gustan hacer porque siempre estamos
pretendiendo que el otro cambie nuestro
sueño con danny es que todos aprendamos
lengua de señas y porque no se
aprendemos inglés francés italiano y
ahora chino mandarín porque no lengua de
señas hoy pudimos demostrarles que hay
un montón de personas que la utilizan
qué lindo sería qué lindo es poder estar
compartiendo momentos en la comunidad
con tu familia o con tus amigos y ser
entendidos donde todos manejemos la
misma lengua
cuando hacemos visibles las necesidades
del otro ocupándonos y preocupándonos es
cuando nuestro interior cambia es decir
que nos pusimos en el lugar del otro
si queremos una sociedad inclusiva no de
palabras sino de hechos
es cuando estamos cambiando entonces
empecemos por nosotros por mirarnos y
por mirar al otro
[Aplausos]
[Música]